[Musique]
cent cinquante mille foyers privés
d'électricité alors qu'il est sur la
moitié nord de la france la tempête
aurore et ses dégâts le trafic sncf est
extrêmement perturbé des arbres
déracinés des branches cassées tombés au
sol la tempête aurore a soufflé plus
fort que prévu ça s'envole c'est un coup
de vent sur le bitcoin 66 mille dollars
hier soir alors qu'il ya 13 ans lorsque
ça a été lancé ça valait autour de 1000
$ la prolongation du passani terre voté
à l'assemblée nationale hier soir le
gouvernement pourra s'il le souhaite
l'utiliser jusqu'au 31 juillet prochain
le vote de cette disposition c'est fait
dans la douleur pour 74 contre 73
votre dérive sur le pass sanitaire ne
passe pas une voix près les marcheurs
qui ne marche pas aussi sûrement qu'hier
au voilà ont failli et oui les députés
d'opposition recouru à la bonne vieille
technique du rideau débarqué au dernier
moment par surprise lors d'un vote pour
mettre en échec la majorité regarder les
bandes de la gauche communiste et
insoumis un quart d'heure plus tôt il
n'y avait personne et au moment du vote
comme par magie hop voilà une nouvelle
quinzaine de députés sont là il consiste
à donner un blanc seing au gouvernement
pour prendre des décisions sanitaire
lesquels proviennent toujours de la même
origine sur quel pied le président de la
république s'est-il lever votre décision
est tellement stupide que dans certaines
régions les soignants viennent à manquer
mais vous proposer qu'ils soient
suspendus je vais vous dire une chose
celui qui devrait être suspendu c'est
vous jettez vous quand je fais ce genre
d'intervention je me demanderais si je
fais la hauteur du mandat que m'ont
confié les français vous venez de me
traiter dans la même phrase de menteur
et de supply je subisse de la république
vous ne respectez pas la république dont
votre leader se traitant à le faire le
représentant à lui tout seul monsieur
députés ah oui pardon bon c'est vrai que
je suis pas à l'élysée donc je dois
porter le masque ici à l'assemblée je
reçois pas les frigos leur dos jours
mais mon masque battu rien j'avais
oublié et à l'intérieur de ce texte de
loi est bien les directeurs
d'établissement pourront demander le
statut vaccinal des élèves et ça fait
bondir l'opposition
je ne sais même pas comment
en pleine nuit comme ça on peut voter
des choses aussi absurde les chefs
d'établissement ram effectivement pour
maintenir parfois un lien ténu avec
certaines familles là non seulement vous
trahissez leur confiance mais vous
trahissez un secret médical qui est
grave et la trahison fait partie de la
vie politique d'une certaine façon je le
regrette mais c'est un fait je pas ici
prendre l'histoire il ya toujours des
successions de personnes qui sont
quelquefois douloureuse nous allons
décider d'une sorte d' indemnité
inflation de 100 euros j'ai parlé de 80
euros tout à l'heure de surcoût de 100
euros qui sera versée
aux français c'est une indemnité classe
moyenne si vous voulez en quelque sorte
aux français qui gagnent moins de 2000
euros net par mois donald trump vient
d'annoncer le lancement de son propre
réseau social vous savez que les murs
n'ont jamais arrêté des gens qui avaient
fait si c'est faux ça avant c'est faux
les murs arrête les gens le mur à la
frontière mexicaine a réduit
l'immigration à quel prix et je m'en
fous
tout le prix ne sera jamais aussi élevé
que la mort du peuple français ils
n'auront rien à faire ce sera
automatique va passer par différentes
circulant en détaillera tout ça dans les
jours à venir il est donc à la fiche de
ce spectacle du réalisateur wes dix mois
z dont il compose donc la musique et se
noie a suscité un véritable tollé sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag nie
tout être un round de cochon greffer sur
un patient humains en état de mort
cérébrale une première mondiale réalisée
par l'équipe du langonnais lth à new
york pendant près de deux jours le corps
du patient et le rein de cochon ont
parfaitement fonctionné ensemble n'est
pas intervenir dans la gestion de la de
la colline je regrette que bertrand
cantat a été invité néanmoins